over the past decade renewable energy
has grown from a niche idea that money
were skeptical of to an energy source
that delivers a significant part of our
country's power needs clean energy is
now one of the world's fastest-growing
industries
despite this continued growth renewable
energy generation in the United Kingdom
fell by 1 percent in 2016 not because of
the decrease in renewable infrastructure
in fact the UK's capacity to generate
renewable energy through by 13.7 percent
it fell because 2016 had less wind and
rained in 2050 drawing energy from such
a highly variable energy source has its
drawbacks forcing us to not over rely on
renewable energy and continue to use
baseload power stations which typically
our fossil fuel power but what if we
could find consistent sources of
renewable energy that were less variable
what if we could build a giant solar
farm in our deserts and transport the
energy across the world without the
worry of losing power through resistance
in the cables or if we could play some
form of wind energy generation high into
the atmosphere where winds are
consistent and blow much faster as I
explained in my video about the future
airliner concept the Aurora T ace when a
solid body like a plane flies through
fluid the fluid near the surface of the
body flows slowly due to friction this
is called a boundary layer the exact
same thing occurs on the surface of the
planet and so as you go higher wind
speeds increase this means the vast
majority of the winds total available
wind energy is located in the upper
atmosphere planes take advantage of this
by flying in jet streams where tail
winds can reach 160 km/h for example a
flight from Dublin to New York takes
nearly an hour longer than a flight from
New York to Dublin wind turbines are
typically placed on mountains to take
advantage of the higher wind speeds but
that obviously has its limits so how can
we reach higher and however spot
valuable wind energy some companies have
designed and built small turbines that
are suspended in the air with a large
helium balloon but these produce very
little power and are not easily scaled
to a larger size another solution is to
use kites last month shell invited me
out to make the future life which is a
festival of ideas and innovation in
London to speak with the inventor of
kite
systems kpx is a UK company which
recently received five million pounds
and investment from Ian slumbering and
shale Technology Ventures which invests
in companies to accelerate the
development and deployment of
technologies to help meet future global
energy needs the more I spoke with KPS
the more the technology makes sense and
I began to see where it could be used in
places where wind turbines couldn't
let's first look at how it works
the system consists of two kites that
are tethered to a spool distilled on
lines of the kite soars through the air
at speeds of up to 160 km/h in a figure
of 8 motion as a spool unwind that
powers an electric generator but also
feeds a hydraulic accumulator the
hydraulic accumulator stores potential
energy in the form of pressure that can
be released to drive the generator to
smoothen out variances and kite speed an
essential quality to make the system's
energy output compliant with the grids
needs to kites are used and allows one
guy to race as the other is lowering
with a small amount of energy from the
kite raising being used to refuel the
chatter of the descended kite this point
confused me initially I could not
understand how this would not reach a
point of equilibrium where the lift on
each kite will equal and the kites will
get stuck but as the chief technology
officer explained to me at make the
future life these are not drag buttons
they're lit bodies with control surfaces
that are controlled by small robotic
part this part insurance the kites are
flying at the optimal fly trajectories
at all times by varying the length of
the bridles from tip to tip the kites
role is controlled and the pitch is
controlled by varying the length between
the frontal back when the kite needs to
be lowered the pitch has changed and the
kite glides back to its start position
so how much energy can these kites
generates KPS is currently building a
500 kilowatt version in the southwest of
Scotland this version uses 216 meter
wide kites for comparison an equivalent
500 kilowatt wind turbine would have a
diameter of around 54 meters these wind
turbines are not cheap being constructed
mostly from Steel on comps and materials
to prevent damage to wind turbines and
strong winds the turbines will be shut
off the kite powered system however can
operate in hurricane-force winds
and in the event of a break the
relatively cheap patter will be the part
that breaks and the kite will be able to
fly itself to the ground as the
controller pot is located on the upper
end of the Tedder if this test location
proves successful KPS has plans to scale
the kite with
megha operation that would consist of
250 meter wide kites where this system
really saves money is reducing loading
on the support structures wind turbine
blades need to be strong enough to
resist both the rotational motion and
bending motion of the wind the tower in
turn need to be strong enough to hold
the weight of the structure and resist
the bending load of the wind and all
this needs to be supported by
substantial foundations both on land and
sea in comparison the kite powered
systems main components that experience
significant loading history the ground
station simply needs to be heavy enough
to prevent the kites from lifting off
the ground this makes the system
significantly cheaper a study published
in 2016 by the International Renewable
Energy Agency founded the cost per
megawatt hour of energy generated by
offshore wind cost about 170 dollars and
that is expected to fall to about $95 by
2030
a study conducted independently of KPS
found a high power could generate a
megawatt hour for 62.5 u.s. dollars by
2020 and 50 USD by 2030 significantly
reducing the cost of offshore wind this
is particularly useful for countries
like Japan do not have a huge amount of
shallow water surrounding them as the
continental shelf dives to 50 to 200
meters too deep for traditional offshore
wind turbines KPS can deploy to these
areas with a simple floating platform
that would be attached to the ocean
floor with cables the onshore version
can even be delivered on a flaw site
that can be deployed in less than a day
potentially being used for disaster
relief situations where energy has been
cut off without a doubt this system has
the potential to revolutionize wind
power Bill Gates has even been quoted
saying that he believes kite power has a
10% chance of being the world's magic
solution to the energy crisis I'd like
to thank shell for inviting me out to
make the future life and giving me the
opportunity to speak directly with the
inventors of the technology that could
help us address the world's energy
challenges as the world's population
grows so does their energy demands and
we're going to need increasing
investments in solutions like KPS to
ensure we can keep producing more energy
with less co2 this year's regional make
the future festivals were held in
Singapore Detroit and London it's a
great event that I highly recommend
checking out when it visits your city I
learned a lot about the future of energy
well there
[Music]